[Musique]
un bon soir un peu plus de 18h dit ça y
est nous sommes en direct bienvenue dans
ce journal de télé 78 et veuillez nous
excuser pour cette prise d'antenne
tardive liées à quelques problèmes
techniques nous sommes le jeudi 14
octobre voici les titres de l'actualité
locale
emmanuel macron sur le terrain pour
l'opération pièces jaunes le président
de la république participe ce jeudi aux
50 ans du variétés club de france à
poissy est de grands noms du sport sont
également présents pour ce match de gala
nous y serons au début de cette édition
la déception et surtout l'énorme
surprise après la révélation ce midi du
parcours du tour de france 2022 la
grande boucle ne s'élancera pas des
yvelines pour la 21e et dernière étape
mais des hauts-de-seine une convention
entre l'organisateur et le département a
pourtant été signé en ce sens en 2019
enfin un adieu les rencontres in cité
lancé en 2017 et place aux labos du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
chaque mois le site organisera ses
rendez-vous en lien avec des spectacles
autour de questions sociétales et
politiques premier numéro ce lundi on en
parle avec lionel masse et à directeur
du théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il faut plus également en tout à l'heure
sur la semaine de l'intégration est des
primo-arrivants des étrangers
primo-arrivants c'est tout à l'heure
dans ce journal
[Musique]
mais direction poissy tout de suite le
stade léo lagrange accueille le gala des
50 ans du variétés club de france un
match qui rassemble cet après midi
plusieurs anciennes stars du football et
c'est au profit de l'opération pièces
jaunes sur place notre journaliste
michael et demi d'euros bonsoir bonsoir
et parmi les joueurs présents sur le
terrain il y en a 1 notamment michael
c'est le président de la république
emmanuel macron oui emmanuel macron est
en très grande forme en ce début de
match il a réalisé quelques crochets et
face aux joueurs du centre hospitalier
intercommunal de poissy à saint germain
de bonne passe également dans les
intervalles pour alain giresse ou encore
christian karembeu
il a même marqué un penalty provoqué par
l'ancien footballeur boulot il a été
acclamé par les 1500 supporters à
présent ici au stade pour l'instant elle
approche de la mi-temps au stade léo
lagrange de poissy 3 en faveur du
variétés club de france avec notamment
un but de sonny anderson le président la
république qui emmanuel macron devrait
jouer à l'intégralité du match les 90
minutes selon à l'elysée je vous
rappelle que l'ensemble des bénéfices
seront reversés à la fondation les
hôpitaux présidée depuis 2019 par à
brigitte macron ujit macron qui est
également présente pour soutenir
emmanuel macron quand cette opération
pièces jaunes vous le dit emmanuel
macron qui devrait jouer normalement
l'intégralité de ce match et il est
aligné au milieu de terrain aux côtés de
rudi garcia l'ancien entraîneur a
notamment de l'olympique de marseille
merci amical on reviendra sur ce passage
des manuels macron sur le terrain demain
dans notre édition du 7 8 week-end et je
remercie également justin brasier qui
vous accompagne pour les moyens
techniques il se dévoile le parcours du
tour de france 2022 a été révélée ce
jeudi à la mi journée depuis le palais
des congrès à paris un départ de
copenhague pour cette 109e édition un
parcours de 3300 28 kilomètres jusqu'aux
champs elysées mais coup de tonnerre la
21e et dernière étape ne partira pas des
yvelines comme à l'accoutumée depuis
quelques années elle les explications
dans ce sujet de céline charles
[Musique]
grosse déception après rambouillet en
2019 mentent en 2020 et chatou en 2021
le tour de france ne partira pas cette
année des yvelines il s'élancera de
paris la défense arena dans les hauts de
seine la surprise est d'autant plus
grande que le département avait signé
une convention en 2019 avec à etsaut
l'organisateur du tour de france cet
accord devait faire des yvelines le
département départ de la 21e étape
jusqu'en 2023 selon nos confrères de
l'écho républicain citant le responsable
presse du tour de france cette option a
été validé par le conseil départemental
des yvelines en mettant en avant le
rapprochement yvelines et hauts de seine
le département de son côté ne s'est pas
exprimé maigre consolation si l'étape ne
partira pas des yvelines elle y passera
tout de même on devrait connaître les
détails du parcours en début d'année
prochaine en 2023 la dernière étape de
la grande boucle devrait partir du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
[Musique]
elle annonce remonte au 30 septembre
dernier l'état entend construire une
deuxième maison d'arrêt dans les
yvelines à magnanville une information
qui a largement fait réagir dans la
commune - collectif d'habitants et de
citoyens s'est formée contre
l'implantation de ce centre
pénitentiaire est de son côté le maire
de magnanville juge brutal la décision
du ministère de la justice celle
interview express réalisé par ses
blagues à tsonga
[Musique]
j'ai été informé il ya à peu près un an
par par l'état qu'il y avait une
réflexion sur suite à la volonté du
président de la république de construire
quinze mille places de prison la cible
est et je dirais leurs réflexions de
l'état était sur ma commune je peux vous
dire qu'aussi et je peux comprendre
l'émoi de la population mais quand on me
l'a dit je suis assez un peu et beaucoup
scotché et non j'ai demandé mais
pourquoi magnanville à l'époque on m'a
indiqué que magnanville était proche de
l'autoroute ban et on n'était pas loin
de versailles etc c'est une maison
d'arrêt donc les gens n'étaient pas
condamné c'était avant jugement et donc
il est en fait
il ya il ya quand même des éléments qui
ont qu une réponse que j'ai posée quand
j'ai eu une entrevue avec garde des
sceaux c'est les questions de mobilité
c'est les questions de sécurité sur les
questions environnementales
c'est des questions aussi d'évaluation
foncière des biens même si on dit dans
les biens l'évaluation des biens va pas
baisser mais les gens ici cela pose ces
questions là donc moi j'ai posé ces
questions là pour l'instant je n'ai pas
de réponses à ces questions là donc
c'est vrai qu'on est à la construction
d'un projet pour l'état mais dans le
même temps je dis sincèrement ces
violences danon ce qui a été fait à la
population et qui est inacceptable
pas de garde des sceaux e-bay il m'a dit
que c'était décision d'êta kangoo et m'a
fait comprendre c'est bien que qu'on
soit informé mais bon on est des cylons
d'état il n'y a pas besoin de
consultation de la population
une consultation des élus
le rôle du collectif qui a été bien en
place parce qu'il est là aussi bas pour
pour apporter et proposer des solutions
aux gens bien entendu des solutions
d'action parce qu' il dise concrètement
ils sont contre la construction de cette
maison d'arrêt et ils vont tout faire
pour que le projet soit abandonné dans
l'actualité également cette annonce du
groupe la poste 172 facteurs vont être
recrutées d'ici la fin de l'année en ile
de france cela concerne 28 postes en cdi
dans le département des yvelines elle
les nouveaux salariés recrutés
bénéficieront d'une formation dédié au
métier la distribution et de son
environnement au management de la santé
à la sécurité au travail pour postuler
rendez vous sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran et jusqu'au 15 octobre
c'est la semaine de l'intégration des
étrangers primo-arrivants l'objectif
présenter les dispositifs d'intégration
des étrangers par les services de l'état
et ses partenaires une réunion était
organisée dans les locaux de france
terre d'asile à versailles ce mercredi
est le reportage de nicolas landry
zulfiqar viennent d'afghanistan lac lui
du sénégal aujourd'hui ils ont le statut
de réfugié suivi par l'association
france terre d'asile ils ont leur propre
logement et une situation
professionnelle zoulficar est auxiliaire
de vie en cdi dans un ehpad l'ate est
soudeur dans une entreprise industrielle
j'aime bien contact avec les gens j'aime
bien aider le personnage et qu'ils ont
besoin dans vie quotidienne grâce à
[Musique]
à
l'accompagnement des vies de
pouvoir faire tout ça et de vivre en
harmonie avec eux et je suis très
content de mon parcours depuis que j'ai
quitté au pays
france terre d'asile accompagne les
demandeurs d'asile et les réfugiés dans
les yvelines deux systèmes sont en place
le dispositif d'accueil d'hébergement et
d'accompagnement des réfugiés le d'art
créée à l'été 2010 950 personnes sont
logées dans 25 logements situés sur neuf
communes des yvelines sa mission c'est à
la fois de les héberger et pendant ce
temps d'hébergement de les accompagner
vers l'autonomie l'accès au droit
l'emploi le logement
qu'ils ne développent des liens avec la
société civile seconde mesure en place
un nouveau projet de france terre
d'asile la plateforme d'accompagnement
et de coordination de l'intégration des
réfugiés lancé dans les yvelines en juin
2021 c'est le dard sans l'accompagnement
vers le logement le logement une
problématique toujours importante vous
savez que l'île de france accueille la
plus grande part des réfugiés en france
on accueille 45 % en ile-de-france de la
demande d'asile et on a une tension qui
est très forte sur le logement donc
c'est difficile malgré une augmentation
assez significative des moyens que
l'état a mobilisé pour accompagner et
accueillir les demandeurs d'asile il ya
encore trop de gens qui ne trouvent pas
de place dans ce qu'on appelle le
dispositif d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile avec des associations comme
france terre d'asile en construit ces
parcours vers le logement avec de belles
réussites pour zoulfikar eilat la
prochaine étape est la demande de
naturalisation
chaque année dans les yvelines près de
quatre mille étrangers arrivent sur le
territoire
[Musique]
un nouveau rendez vous au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lundi le site
lancera son premier labo les labos du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
remplacent les rencontres in cité qui
était en place depuis 2010 est et on en
parle avec lionel messi est un bon soir
bonsoir directeur du théâtre qu'est ce
qui change concrètement entre ces
rencontres in cité et ses labos du
théâtre et bien concrètement les
rencontres et de citer était un temps
événementiel pendant une semaine c'était
en relief de la programmation là les
labos sont totalement intégrés dans la
programmation mais l'intention est la
même et on a des sujets peut-être plus
large de société c'est vrai que les
rencontres c'était très porté sur la
science est ce que là on va avoir des
thèmes plus larges bases il ya toujours
une acception de la semaine de la
science assez large c'est à dire que ce
soit des sciences dures des sciences
molles des sciences humaines on appelle
ça comme on veut
on est toujours sûr c'est sur deux sur
des thématiques qui sont d'une certaine
façon scientifique scientifique et
sociétal
les rencontres une cité il y avait une
thématique avec un certain nombre de
tables rondes de spectacles et de films
qui tournait autour de cette thématique
là on va avoir huit labo donc huit
thématiques différentes huit soirées
différentes et donc le format ça se
déroule sur une soirée et des
intervenants à chaque fois ouais il ya
des intervenants il ya une journaliste
qui nous a aidés à concevoir l'ensemble
de ces de ces soirées chaque soir il ya
un modérateur une modératrice il ya deux
ou trois invités alors ça peut être des
journalistes des scientifiques parce que
c'est aussi important et ça c'est ce qui
présidé à l'organisation des rencontres
incité comment est ce que la parole
scientifique peut rentrer dans un
théâtre est en résonance avec le geste
artistique donc des scientifiques des
chercheurs des praticiens également ça
peut être des responsables associatifs
des personnes qui s'engagent sur le
terrain en fonction de la thématique du
la peau c'est une heure de tables rondes
des changes qui ont été anticipées qui
ont été construits et ensuite une demi
heure de parole et des changes entre la
salle et les invités et vous le disiez
c'est lié à chaque fois avec un
spectacle qui est dans la programmation
du théâtre oui on appris
là alors c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même
un une un tropisme dans la programmation
du théâtre de saint quentin c'est à dire
qu'on est très attaché à un certain
nombre de thématiques sociétales c'est à
dire comment est ce que l'art finalement
réagi ou contre réagit à ce qui se passe
dans la société comment il s'en inspire
ce qui veut dire que lorsqu'on égrène
lorsqu'on prend la totalité de la
programmation se rend compte qu'il ya
une dizaine une quinzaine une vingtaine
de thématiques assez forte qui sont
vraiment en relief et c'est un choix
dans ces différentes thématiques qui
nous a fait choisir par exemple sur le
premier le premier labo la question du
sida et de façon très étrange
complètement déconnecté de la question
de l'épidémie que nous avons traversée
c'est vrai que ça entre en résonance
avec l'épidémie mais c'est pas en lien
avec ça qu'on a voulu traiter de cette
thématique
voilà il y en a plein d'autres l'égalité
homme femme qui traverse une partie de
la programmation une programmation qui
est sainte qui quittent qui est
totalement paritaire au théâtre de saint
quentin donc voilà c'est comme ça que
l'on travaille et on voit les
thématiques qui résonne avec les
thématiques qui qui questionne les gens
les citoyens aujourd'hui
voilà c'est qu'ils sont de plus de qui
nous semble le plus intéressant de la
solution et variés effectivement de
l'égalité hommes femmes ces voix là
c'est des thématiques qui sont en lien
vous lisez avec des sujets de société
des sujets d'actualité aussi parce qu'on
va parler notamment dans ses labos des
élections il ya une thématique autour de
la campagne électorale qui se déroulera
en mars un mois avant la présidentielle
donc il y avait des liens avec
l'actualité oui oui il ya un lien un
spectacle s'appelle le grand débat qui
est une
une sorte de concentré de des débats de
la présidentielle depuis 1974 jusqu'à la
dernière élection est le dernier débat
télévisé on parle du débat du second
tour donc là on va travailler sur et on
s'est toujours posé la question enfin
moi je me suis toujours posé la question
de comment les sujets montety dans
l'actualité comment les sujets
deviennent t-il tout d'un coup
omniprésent alors même que la moitié des
sujets qui sont traités ne sont pas les
sujets essentiels ils ne font pas partie
de nos préoccupations essentielles du
préoccupation essentielle du monde donc
c est cette chose là c'est la place des
lobbys la place des communicants dans la
politique est ce que le débat de fond
est éclipsée par des questions purement
politicienne avec le d'autres
thématiques on peut citer aussi là
l'impact des réseaux sociaux sur les
adolescents notamment plaint thématiques
et vous le disiez à huile à hbo qui sont
prévues cette saison le premier labo
d'ailleurs c'est lundi prochain à 19h30
le thème c'est le sida raconter et
transmettre la mémoire d'une épidémie
parce qu'on a peut-être tendance à
l'oublier vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
il ya au delà du colis 19 d'autres
épidémies qui sont plus vieilles qui ont
été plus dévastatrice le sida continue
de tuer aujourd'hui plus de 38 millions
de personnes vivent avec le vih dans le
monde pourquoi vouloir débuter avec avec
cette thématique basse est rentré en
résonance avec un spectacle que le
théâtre de saint quentin co produit qui
s'appelle né suis jamais de larmes sans
gants qui était une consigne donnée par
le personnel médical aux infirmières qui
font partie aussi du personnel médical
ou dans les années 80 quand les premiers
malades du sida sont arrivés sont
arrivés dans les dents des dans les
hôpitaux et dans les cliniques
dont elle avait ce spectacle là le sida
et vous le rappeliez tu aujourd'hui
encore six cent mille personnes 600
mille malades par an c'est quand même
énorme et pourtant on parle finalement
assez peu de cette maladie en
coproduisant cette pièce qui parle
rapidement de d'une histoire d'amour
dans le stockholm des années 80 au
moment où le sida arriver comment ça
absolument tout tout dévaster d'abord au
prélat des homosexuels ou des personnes
qui voilà qui se pique
ça se passe à ce moment là et je me
disais pour une jeune génération peau de
génération qui a 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans
est absolument aucune connaissance de
cette période là et pourtant cette
période là elle a été extrêmement
importantes dans nos rapports sociaux
moi qui viens d'un petit village du
sud-ouest de 800 habitants j'ai eu deux
amis qui sont décédés du sida donc ça a
touché absolument tout le monde pas
uniquement les gens qui sortaient au
palace dans les années 80 mais
absolument tout le monde et toutes les
couches de la société on avait envie de
revenir sur 7 sur cette question là mais
donc quel est le programme qui sont les
intervenants de cette soirée les
intervenants nous avons deux personnes
qui interviennent une personne et qui
est chercheur et qui travaille pour le
sidaction et une autre personne philippe
mangeot qui a été président d'act up qui
a participé également à la au scénario
de 120 battements par minute le film de
camping et donc il était vraiment au
coeur de la tempête dans les dents dans
ces années là et donc ce premier labo
c'est ce lundi 19h30 scellier aussi vous
le disiez un autre spectacle né suis
jamais de larmes sans gants qui est
prévue les 20 et 21 octobre le 20
octobre à 20h30 le 21 octobre à 19h30
adapté du roman éponyme de genas gardel
et s'est proposé par le collectif 18.3
une dernière question pourquoi le
théâtre justement aussi une mission
d'organiser ce genre d'événement au delà
de proposer un des spectacles de la
culture pourquoi aussi aller plus loin
dans ses réflexions peut-être parce que
tout simplement parce que les théâtres
quand ils sont professionnels
professionnaliser sans se sont un peu
éloignés de ce qu'on appelait
l'éducation populaire qui est un vilain
terme aujourd'hui mais avec lequel moi
j'aime bien renouer en théâtre c'est
fait aussi pour apprendre à penser à
réfléchir au delà même du spectacle et
donc c'est la beauce et une entrée libre
mais sur inscription toutes les infos
bien sûr sur le site du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci lionel
masse état d'être venu en parler merci à
vous mais je rappelle vous êtes le
directeur de ce théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
[Musique]
le retour à dimanche dernier à présent
la deuxième cycle au cancer se déroulait
à maurepas organisé par le club cyclo
tourisme de la ville pour cette nouvelle
édition six circuits à vélo et à pied
était proposé 500 participants ont
répondu présents et des dons collectés
au profit du service pédiatrique du
centre hospitalier de versailles dans la
prise en charge de la douleur ce service
suit cette année une quarantaine
d'enfants poids cancer 6500 euros ont pu
être ainsi récoltés cette année les
propos recueillis par mélanie poké et
patrick jacques de dixmude
on
cherche là aujourd'hui c'est améliorer
vraiment l'accompagnement de l'enfant et
de sa famille au travers des soies qui
sont parfois douloureux et nous avons le
projet d'acquérir des casques de réalité
virtuelle qui vont permettre de diminuer
le ressenti de la douleur pendant les
soins cette année on a rajouté pédaler
et marché pour une bonne cause donc ça
je pense que c'était très important
d'être dans une démarche multi
associations et on le voit bien on a
presque deux tiers de cyclistes un tiers
de marcheurs donc c'est un réel
engouement associatif et avant de vous
laisser un verger participative à voir
bientôt le jour à montigné voisins le
bretonneux c'est l'un des onze secteurs
identifiés par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines pour développer des
projets d'agriculture urbaine une
première réunion s'est tenue cette
semaine à ce sujet mélanie poquet et
bixente mayence insisté ban
voyez par exemple à quoi ressemblera le
futur verger participatif de la
sourderie c'était l'objectif du premier
atelier auquel ont participé une
quarantaine d'habitants des communes de
voisins-le-bretonneux et montigny le
bretonneux qui peut amener aussi de la
biodiversité des oiseaux des insectes
voilà remettre de la vie en fait dans
une zone qui apparemment actuellement
n'est qu'une longue une vulgaire pelouse
quoi on a travaillé sur plus
l'organisation le comment ça va se
mettre en place la gouvernance
les aspects plus pratiques et les
valeurs qu'on souhaite transmettre dans
ce dans ces rejets c'est une parcelle de
5000 mètres carrés au bord du plan d'eau
qui a été retenu à l'issue de cet
atelier les idées vont être compilées
par un paysagiste et d expert en
arboriculture
les participants sont accompagnés de
plusieurs associations comme ce qui en
transition ce qui pousse et vergers
urbain on va pas jusqu'au 21 large et
après on s'arrête là on a du suivi et de
l'accompagnement donc des formations au
cours de l'année 2022 sur la taille de
formation des arbres fruitiers sur la
greffe rue thiers sur les différents
thèmes de la biodiversité au verger etc
les premières plantations sont prévues
au printemps prochain ce projet entre
dans le cadre du plan climat et du
développement de l'agriculture locale et
des circuits courts de l'agglomération
adopté en 2019 dans
l'agriculture urbaine pour ce
développement on a
repérez 11 secteur dans les 12 communes
de l'agglomération
sur lesquels il nous semble possible de
faire ses premiers développements un
écho pâturages va aussi bientôt voir le
jour sur le même espace les moutons sont
attendus le 22 octobre prochain un
deuxième secteur est en développement le
val favery à coignières
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité demain vendredi même
heure j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver en compagnie de bixente mais
rien senti steban pour le sais tu ce
week-end une émission avec de
l'actualité mais aussi des idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]